l'arrêt de fessenheim incarne l'écologie
de responsabilité porté par le président
de la république le gouvernement et la
majorité depuis 2010 est avec cette
décision nous tenons nos promesses
nous transformons en profondeur notre
modèle énergétique et nous accompagnons
les français et les territoires dans
cette transformation avec l'arrêt des
deux réacteurs de fessenheim nous
engageons la réduction à 50% de la part
du nucléaire d'ici 2035 tout en
développant massivement les énergies
renouvelables pourquoi parce qu'un
système électrique plus diversifiée est
un système plus résilients et c'est pour
ça que nous allons multiplier par deux
la part de l'éolien et parfums que la
part du photovoltaïque dans les dix ans
mais dans le même temps le gouvernement
et particulièrement vigilant à
l'accompagnement des salariés et des
territoires
s'agissant des salariés d'edf ils seront
tous reclassés au sein du groupe
et s'agissant des salariés des sous
traitants une cellule de reclassement
est en place pour les accompagner
concernant la reconversion du territoire
35 millions d'euros ont déjà été engagés
et il est vrai que la crise a conduit à
prendre du retard dans les mises en
place des différents dispositifs
mais je voudrais souligner l'annoncé
récente du d'un projet d'implantation
d'une usine de biocombustibles qui
pourrait générer 700 emplois dans le
territoire donc soyez assurés madame la
sénatrice que notre politique
énergétique s'inscrit pleinement dans le
respect des accords de paris de l'accord
de paris et que nous accompagnons les
français et les territoires dans la
transition